bonsoir donc tout d'abord à Sori
Ibrahima Diakité bonsoir et bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes le maire de
cette commune de Kona au Mali et bonsoir
à Jacques maréchal vous êtes le
président d'Eden et c'est vous qui êtes
à l'origine de cette venue justement du
maire de ConA en France dans les dans
les ivelines pourquoi cette invitation
bien écoutez pour une raison simple
c'est que nous ne pouvons pas nous
déplacer et aller au Mali que ça fait un
certain temps que N n'ons pas eu un
contact direct avec le maire de Ka et
nous voulions faire le point après 3 ans
de fonctionnement pour la continuité de
l'opération la lumière à conona où nous
faisons des investissements en
photovoltaïque pour l'éclairage et
l'électrification rurale de cette belle
commune on va parler justement de cette
opération du partenariat qui est né
entre entre ces deux pays entre votre
association et puis votre commune
auparavant peut-être un mot sur votre
commune aussi c'est cette ville qui a
été prise en premier par les extrémistes
ce qui a déclenché l'intervention au
Mali des des forces Fran française
aujourd'hui quelle est la situation euh
avant de commencer d'abord je tenais
tout juste à vous remercier de m'inviter
sur votre plateau merci à vous eu la
France elle est ce qu'elle est elle a
été responsable
elle a été responsable diligente et
puis elle est arrivé à un moment bien
précis h par rapport à l'arrivée des
terroristes dans notre territoire h et
quelle est la situation alors
aujourd'hui dans votre actuellement là
où nous sommes la situation elle est
elle elle vit bien elle vit bien puisque
les choses commencent à tourner et la
population est revenue eu le commerce
est un peu florissant d'accord et tout
bien tout le monde est là et que
seulement
euh je dirais à Monsieur Jacques je
souhaiterai l'invité au village pour
qu'il sente que tout va bien là-bas et
que la piscose aussi a disparu comment
vous avez vécu cette période de de
conflit cette période où les terroristes
sont arrivés ou aussi le travail de
l'association ont ét rendu encore plus
difficile ben
infernal infernal les djadistes sont
arrivés à un moment où on s'attendait
pas puisque chez nous d'abord conna
était la ligne de front h il y avait
bien de il y avait bien de militaires
qui étaient là et tout le tout le monde
qui était au nord croyant que avec la la
la présence des militaires maliens sur
notre territoire
et pouvait les sauver mais
malheureusement que quand ils sont
arrivés on a trouvé le le contraire et
on s'est on a quitté le village et puis
on s'est retrouvé de l'autre côté du
fleuve alors tiens-toi bien nous sommes
partis avec nos nos déplacés également
mais en ce qui concerne nos partenaires
heureusement pour nous ça n'a pas été
atteint h euh
Eden je ne pouvais je ne peux pas dire
que Eden euh vraiment m'a créé beaucoup
de problèmes puisque j'ai eu plein de
jaloux par rapport à des installations
qui ma promis m'a fait m'a installé dans
ma commune si bien que toutes les
communes voisines sont là aujourd'hui en
train de me faire la guerre et comment
j'ai pu trouver comment j'ai pu trouver
des partenaires de ce genre très sérieux
qui m'ont four de l'électricité et
comment justement s'est passé le le le
partenariat comment il est né ce
partenariat entre votre association Eden
et puis aussi juste une question pendant
pendant la période où le conflit a
dégénéré vous avez coupé les ponts vous
êtes resté en contact régulièrement
absolument pas coupé les ponts mais on a
la chance d'avoir sur le territoire
une ONG qui s'appelle action Mopti qui
travaille depuis 20 ans sur le Mali à
Mopti qui est à 60 km de Ka et grâce à
cet
ONG qui a quand même plus de 40
personnes permanentes à Mopti nous avons
là un relais pour travailler pour
pouvoir faire notre action c'estàd que
action Mopti est notre correspondant
local et sur nos indications il prend
contact avec les responsable fait des
appels d'offres nécessaires pour faire
les installations c'est notre partenaire
sur le terrain et sans cette
participation on nurait pas pu mener à
bien notre opération de d'investissement
de
formation on a fait d'ailleurs une
évaluation suite à ça il y a un degré de
satisfaction qui est de l'ordre de 95 à
99 % donc c'est extraordinaire et même
dans la période difficile moi je tiens à
souligner le le comportement des
collectivités locales au Mali on peut
dire sans langue de bois qu'au niveau
gouvernemental national ça a été un peu
un effondrement politique et de gestion
administrative du pays mais les
collectivités locales ont tenu les
maires étaient à leur place ont pris
leur responsabilité
et en face de nous les interlocuteurs
même pendant les événements les plus
dramatiques lors de ce séjour en France
qui a débuté il y a quelques jours vous
avez déjà déjà rencontré des députés des
représentants du du ministère de la
Coopération aussi avant avant de avant
de répondre à vos question je tenais sur
ce micro remercier action Mopti qui
vraiment euh s'est investi pour la
réussite de notre partenariat avec Eden
h et chapeau au coordinateur surtout en
ce qui concerne ma venue à Paris à Paris
ici c'est Eden h euh c'est qui m'a
invité et vous avez pu rencontrer donc
vous avez eu accès ces députés ces
représentants du minist député quel
bilan vous faites de j'ai rencontré le
député échanges j'ai rencontré le député
de Mar mé oui Jean-Philippe m député de
la 11e
circonscriptionàre j'ai rencontré aussi
le le maire l'avrière Alen ajaz j'ai
rencontré plein de gens et vraiment et
que je sens que quelle était la nature
des échanges de quoi avez-vous discuté
avec eux ben nous avons discuté sur le
renforcement de de nos de notre
partenariat avec Eden et nous sommes en
train de nous battre h Eden est en train
de se battre pour qu'on puisse avoir
d'autres partenaires qui puissent les
aider pour qu'il vienne en secours
justement c'est ça c'est ça le motif de
ma venue et vous êtes confiant justement
sur bien sûr je suis confiantur je suis
confient et certain que c'est une
réussite vous avez mené avec
l'association Eden ce projet
d'électrification par panneau
photovoltaïque des des villages qui
n'était pas accordé au au réseau où on
est ce projet est-ce qu'il y en a
d'autres et ben on continue hein là pour
l'instant
c'est quand même pas loin de 50000
habitants qu'il faut relier à
l'électricité avec des moyens qui sont
modestes il est clair que c'est un
travail de longue haline le Mali n pas
me structuré comme la France il y a pas
de réseau électrique il y a aucun réseau
donc il est pas question que ka un jour
soit relié à un réseau électrique donc
pour l'électricité bah il faut faire des
petites unités soit individuelles soit
des petits groupes des petites toute
petite centrale et il est hors de
question d'espérer un jour d'avoir un
réseau électrique à conin c'est clair
donc on est là pour un bon moment euh
c'était avec plaisir qu'on qu'on
travaille là-bas parce que on les gens
sont ont une reconnaissance à la France
qui ma fois est tout à fait sympathique
pour l'action qu'on mène là-bas quoi on
dit que la communauté malienne est très
implantée en Île-de-France dans les
ivelines c'est le casou oui oui tout à
fait tout à fait d'ailleurs on a
rencontré encore ce matin quelqu'un moi
que je connaissais par ailleurs euh mais
qui est qui se trouve de la famille de
Monsieur diquité c'est un peu une grande
famille les Maliens ils sont tous en
famille ici quoi quels sont pour
conclure les besoins à l'heure actuelle
de votre commune les les besoins actuels
de notre commune c'est que avec les
contacts que j'ai pris avec le président
jacqu Jacques Marchall ben on a des
promesses et ces promesses sont
fructueus déjà je peux vous le
dire ben les problèes sont C qu'elles
sont et je crois que ce partenariat
serait beaucoup plus renforcé h euh
davantage sinon tout de suite déjà euh
je devais je dois rencontrer le conseil
d'administration demain et là on va
arrêter ce qu'il faut faire sinon ça
promet on peut dire que euh
l'intervention militaire française a été
d'arrêter les
rebelles terroristes et pour se faire
ils étaient dans la mairie et dans dans
la sous-préfecture de conard les
terroristes donc l'armée française
l'aviation a bombardé la mairie et la
sous-préfecture donc aujourd'hui
première reconstruction c'est le au
centre de conal la mairie la
sous-préfecture il y a eu quand même
monsieur diquité me disait pas loin de
500 terroristes d'éliminés dans la zone
hein et bon c'est là que le premier mort
de l'armée française a été tué le
lieutenant
boiteux donc c'est c'est c'est quand
même le point le plus où sont passé les
choses les plus dures de cette
intervention cale au Mali il a encore s
travail de reconstruction à mener et
continuer le travail que vous aviez
débuté je le jeune le jeune lieutenant
Damian boî le premier à tomber sur le
territoire
malien nous sommes en train de vouloir
l'immortaliser h le 4 mai de ce mois le
président de la République a passé à
ConA pour une
la rue porta le nom de Damien boiteu h
en même temps il a fait des cadeaux à
son homonyme la femme qui a accouché le
jour où il est tombé ce garçon porte le
nom de Damien boîux et actuellement nous
sommes en train de vouloir monter un
projet ou du moins on a monté un projet
pour faire une grande satuette de Damien
boî tout juste à la rentrée de la rue de
Damien boitu donc il y a un vrai lien
très fort entre entre vot comme entre
pays entre votre commune principalement
et la France merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau pour nous expliquer le travail
qui est mené notamment par l'association
Eden sur place et demain pour ceux
peut-être qui voudrai échanger avec vous
directement si jamais peut-être aussi
des de la communauté malienne vous serez
présent sur le marché de trappe c'est ça
ça fait partie de la visite qui était
prévue voilà si jamais à l'occasion vous
pouvez rencontrer le maire de cette
commune de ConA qui était avec nous ce
soir merci à vous merci aussi Jacques
maréchal donc président de l'association
Eden